[Musique]
e
elle n'en finit plus de vous séduire
quesnel en chant hypnotise par sa voix
et sa musique elle remonte sur scène ici
aux bichiques là où nous allons
la retrouver merci kheneg nous
accueillir ici à saint benoît au bicycle
a où tu vas retrouver la scène a
récemment tu as fait un buzz avec un
cover de wade n est-ce que tu t'y
attendais pas du tout alors franchement
moi je sortais du boulot j'ai écouté ou
hd je me suis dit bon allez on va là la
filmer la post et je m'endors et je me
réveille avec 200 milles vu des milliers
de partage ce que j'ai d'habitude on est
moi et franchement c'était génial je
m'attendais pas du tout j'étais bien je
crois que jeter dans le même chemin
leno j'ai rêvé d'être
le contact avec ton public
ouais mais c'était pas prévu du tout
c'était vraiment pour me fait plaisir et
le fait plaisir à eux et ça a bien
fonctionné
la musique tu a baigné dedans depuis
toute petite tu chantes tout le temps
ouais je pense même jeu soul ma famille
je chante tout le temps tout le temps et
aujourd'hui quand on regarde un peu ton
parcours chacun des titres on peut le
dire est devenu un tube
qu'est ce qui t'inspire quand tu écris
c'est surtout ce que je vois autour de
moi parce que je suis quelqu'un qui
observe beaucoup et jusqu'à cas de
trésors patick donc si j'entends une
histoire que quelqu'un aime raconter qui
me touche ça va m'inspirer pour mes
chansons mais voilà on voit aussi le
côté religieux qui est très important
c'est plus que le religieuse gérée c'est
plutôt le côté spirituel
voilà
ces modèles
et c'est cool
l'émission
et après
osez la thyroïde
comme il
c'est d'une façon d'apporter des
messages au public ou une façon de te
libérer toi c'est une bonne question
c'est un peu des deux donc c'est vrai
que les mots guérissent les mots m ax et
je me suis dit bon ben si je peux me
guérir mois et peut-être guéret un petit
peu les autres et c'est tout bénéfique
en fait et on le voit avec la chanson
bondier ça c'est quelque chose qui a
fait l'unanimité peu importe ce qu'on
pense ou ce concert d'un comme religion
est ce que tu t'attendais à ce succès là
non plus non plus n'ont en fait je
devais faire une opération et je me suis
dit bon allez laisse une trace de toi
qu'elle veut parents s'est jamais
attaqué ce qui peut se passer dans la
vie et c'est vrai que ça a tout de suite
pris son envol
mais de manière waouh quoi
comment
tél
[Musique]
si tu attends du concert qui va ben
lloris est de retrouver la chaleur
humaine même s'il ya des distanciation
tout ça je sais que l'union fait
toujours la force et c'est vraiment ça
c'est l'esprit de retrouvailles avec le
public la chaleur humaine chanter ce
simplement devant quelqu'un parce que
c'est vrai je suis hantée champ tout le
temps mais devant des shampoings c'est
pas pareil d'avoir des personnes non
mais c'est ça qu'est ce que tu aimerais
que les gens retiennent de toi
franchement je sais pas quelqu'un de
simple et de 13 ouvéa quelqu'un de
positif
en fait moi j'aimerais juste aider les
gens il ya des choses que les gens
n'osent pas dire et moi j'aimerais que à
travers mes chansons s'ils n'osent pas
le dire et de le vivre voix ils prennent
ma chanson il faut écouter a qui veulent
faire passer un message quoi ça ça
serait chouette mais moi j'aimerais
vraiment que les gens apprennent à être
vraiment qu'ils sont parce que ça sert à
quoi d'être comme quelqu'un d'autre si
on peut être soi même
merci qu'ils en espèrent encore entendre
des messages de toi merci merci à vous
me
wade dans moquer et même quand sarah
comme on voudrait voulaient la peau mais
manquaient pas konaté la lumière ou ça
trappe des trois étoiles et même quand
il fait noir haute l'amour les mots fana
[Musique]